okay so tell me about like when you get
to the field like a little game day
routine so I get there probably like
noon you know I eat lunch then I go to
the training table yep you stretched out
for a little bit go go to the field get
like probably like 45 minutes of
treatment just like loosen up chill for
a little bit I'll get loose in the cage
I'll stretch maybe do a little defensive
work get a little bite to eat take it
like a 45 minute nap oh nap guys just
started I started this you know I think
you enjoy that I enjoyed that some days
I nap some days I just go in there and
chill yeah yeah you know it's more about
the just the rest just the rest the
hitters meeting I'm gonna go over to go
over the start of that night before
getting the tubs shower up then get in
the cage again so you try and get there
early so you don't have to rush through
it yeah take your time I don't like
Russia so